Van Fleet Pines Lowery quick release on
a three
Leonard sneaks in against the offensive
rebound back to Lowery
[Applause]
[ __ ] Dawa
Steph Curry high-speed inside the
draymond Green siakam the plate tops
amount of direct coke comes to help
Leonard's left open good look from
siakam baseline side Leonard just sneaks
behind curry bumped some excellent pass
by Sayaka and a good finish future
talked about it this is the best those
backdoor at the pass
kicks it out wide open Iguodala
hesitated though Murray now contested
three that's good there's that first
field goal from Steph Curry and fleet
gets inside feets took a soul misses
badly
draymond Green fleshly throws ahead got
a bad pass Leonard with the steal
winners back to Gasol
lays it up and in ten point Toronto lead
curry for three
again Steph Curry with his second
straight three-pointer won't go and he
Baco just checked in tips it and Looney
must definitely be hurt because they
went to Bogut as Lenny puts it in
well good attack by Leonard the behind
the back and then attacking clock at six
Leonard double-team knocked away by klay
Thompson Perry ahead of the pack the
sole in pursuit and it goes for Steph
Curry now with 14 points they do a good
job of hanging around in spite of
adversity they battle they compete and
give themselves he passed it twice
sprint it flight four steps behind a
three Leonard fine - boom
despite we get surrounded the first
thing they say what makes it so hard to
defend it is how strong he is how strong
his hands on curry throws it up when
Andrew bumped it just in what an
absolute luxury quarter that's already
six turnovers
well curry with the catch and Ibaka
shows up a little bit on a stunting
State trying to even up these finals at
one game apiece
Leonard harassed by Greene foul shots go
ahead one
siakam gets way up into curry final
minute third quarter curry long
three-putts it in chef curry from way
downtown and it's back up to ten the
ball movement at Steve Kerr saying after
Game one this the best passing team
we've seen Leonard for three
[Applause]